let me pull up this tweet from you
actually
so uh corey a deangelis on twitter says
the gop is a golden opportunity to
become the parents party and you linked
to this uh this data showing that
republicans are now favored on the issue
of education for basically the first
time ever
is it really ever
yeah well according to this chart it's
going back two decades at least and i
don't recall a time of democrats ever
being uh down on the issue of education
this is a seismic shift it's like a
double-digit swing in the other
direction
this is apocalyptic for the left yep
because as we often mentioned and i i'm
not i don't mean to be crass they're
substantially more likely
to abort their their children
they're substantially more likely to
give drugs to their children which will
prevent the ability to reproduce
they're substantially more likely just
in general not to have families
so the saying goes leftists don't have
kids they have yours
they need to be able to convert the
children of moderates and conservatives
otherwise their ideology ceases to exist
and this is why terry mcauliffe in
virginia had to say i don't think
parents should be telling schools what
they should teach it's a deeply
ingrained belief that the kids belong to
the government schools this idea that it
takes a village well it turns out it's a
deeply unpopular belief especially after
the school system treated families so
bad after the past couple of years and i
think the opponent the republican glenn
younkin tapped into something which
could be a blueprint for success for the
gop and libertarians as well uh going
forward because how are you going to
defend that
this idea that parents shouldn't have a
say in their kids education yeah it's
insane for any ideology too it doesn't
just because it happens to be um on the
backs of people that were like talking
to kids about sexuality it doesn't
matter you wanna talk to kids about
religion and tell them not tell their
parents it's still messed up you still
don't do that stuff we have entrusted
the public schools they violated trust
in my opinion can you like real quick
give an exam like explain what school
choice exactly is yeah the money that
would have followed you to the
government-run school on average in the
u.s according to 2019 data from the
census bureau was about 16 000
per kid wow if you want to take it to
the government school you can if you
like your public school you can keep
your public school but for real but if
not about half of the funding or so
depending on the law that you pass will
follow the child
usually to something called an education
savings account which the parents could
use for private school tuition for a
charter school for home-based learning
options like a micro school for example
it's the idea that the money follows the
child it's time to start calling this
universal school access yeah we advocate
for universal school access for all
children
you oppose access to schooling for
children you monster
with
i just call it funding students not
systems it puts the other side on
defense because if you want to fight
against me you have to argue why we
should fund the system and not the
student so it's sure i'm going to call
it universal school access i'm in favor
of both universal school access for for
all families usa
listen listen a impoverished family
should have the right to get access to
the school for their kids that they
think is right for them don't you i mean
you don't think we should segregate
schools do you no and i think that well
there we go kids in incredibly violent
dangerous inner city school systems
should be able to go to school somewhere
else if
if the funding is there uh honestly you
know from a libertarian perspective i
say just get rid of as much public
education as possible but if if it's
going to be a fight to do that let's
take every step possible and at least
let these poor kids have a choice it's
it's brutal public school is a brutal
violent place for a lot of children oh
yeah yep i certainly know that it's
terrible yeah you were homeschooled
right well
briefly so before kindergarten my mom
homeschooled me my brother my sister uh
i think
as the story goes we were homeschooled
the moment we were alive yeah like she
was always you know trying to show us
things
and then um i think i learned how to
play chess when i was like three not
that i was good at it i'm not saying
that but like i was being explained and
taught the moves of a chess board and
stuff like that
and then when uh
me and my siblings we were going to
school we already knew our basic math
before even kindergarten
we started with catholic school which
was private my family chose it because i
thought it was a better school and then
hard times uh after fifth grade we moved
to a public school and wow i think this
is one of the greatest experiences of my
life to be honest going from this this
uh private catholic school which was
very strict
but um not particularly harsh just it
was like very rigid like if you didn't
have your tie you got a misconduct slip
and you had to go home and get it signed
and it was like oh no you know if you're
a little sailor tie and then you go to
this public school where
nobody did anything and like you didn't
have your homework who cares what are
you going to do about it the kids were
doing drugs
and then for me to be thrust into that i
think was actually a really good thing
because i had discipline from a private
school private catholic school then i
got to experience the real world very
very quickly and so i was like okay i
don't want to do those things i see why
they're bad
but i also see real life so there was a
net benefit to having experience from a
more disciplined place
and then realizing just how bad public
schools were
i mean i i got to tell you like going
from a private school which you know
they have their problems too it's like
it's perfect and then going to a public
schools like i was not even in school it
was like
daycare basically yeah
yeah which a lot of parents didn't get
uh starting in march of 2020 and then
you had some
people in the school system saying i'm
doing my job i'm educating through zoom
but it's like well if
but one of the side benefits of the
school system is that you have in-person
child care services
and
taxpayers want to have agreed to pay 15
16 000 per year i would say they don't
agree in the current situation either
but they certainly wouldn't have agreed
to raise taxes as much as they have if
the only benefit you were getting was
something that could be
done via khan academy for free how about
zoom detention remember that yeah log in
to zoom and stare at a blank screen for
you have the cops come to your house if
there was a nerf gun behind you on the
wall that happened too i had saturday
detention once
i was i was high school very briefly and
i remember what happened i think i cut
class or something because it was just
so awful and then uh they did this thing
where they changed our schedule so we're
you know i'm in eighth grade and it's
like 7 30 in the morning until 2 30 is
school and then when we start high
school the local high school says we're
doing 10 45 a.m to 5 30 p.m which was
like a huge shock to all of the freshmen
coming in so i was just like this is
ridiculous and i left so i come back and
they're like saturday detention for you
and then i was like what happens if i
don't come and set a detention like you
get another one and i was like okay and
what happens if i don't go to that and
they're like you get another one and i
was like i don't think you're
understanding
what this means and i'm like okay and
then i just didn't go like nothing
happened
it's nonsense even then now zoom
detention is funny it's like turn your
tablet on and then sit in your room i
guess you're like playing video games i
mean and at the same time you had the
the teachers union board members
vacationing in puerto rico saying
there's no way i can go to work in
person but i can be sitting here on the
beach uh tweeting out uh photos on
instagram well if it was safe enough to
travel on vacation why wasn't it safe
enough to go back to work either full of
it man
and you know it doesn't even matter i i
don't want to have a political argument
over schools with like like teachers in
the unions i'm like my attitude is
strictly you know hey good for them if
you like your teachers and you like
what's going on that's really really
great for you i think we need universal
school access for kids
and you know that way
you know not every teacher is good and
so the parents need to decide you know
what the proper schooling is and they
shouldn't be barred from that so if you
have a kid who's in
let me ask you this is it unreasonable
if you have a kid who lives in a poor
area the parents should be allowed to
have that kid go to a wealthier
neighborhood school right yep that's
universal universal school access that's
so that's what we're fighting for for
the underprivileged inner city kids to
go to where the rich white kids get to
go right and if you look at the uh
the percentage of people from different
backgrounds who are using these existing
programs it tends to be lower income
families charter schools you look at
national center for education statistics
data more likely to have a higher
proportion of non-white students and
more likely to have a higher proportion
of low-income students you look at the
d.c voucher program for example where i
live and the average household income of
students using that program i think is
about twenty eight thousand dollars per
household in dc
uh 95 percent of the students using the
program in dc are black or hispanic yet
you had the biden administration coming
out against uh the program uh with
funding following the job what's their
argument against universal school access
you're stealing money from the public
schools to which i respond
the money doesn't belong to the
government schools education funding is
meant for educating the child not for
propping up and protecting a particular
institution why should poor children be
barred from going to the fancier wealthy
private schools we should guarantee
universal school access so the families
can can you know get a voucher and go to
the wealthy private school or the public
school in the better area
universal school what's funny is the
left supports a whole bunch of
initiatives that allow public money
taxpayer funding to follow the decision
of the family for or student for higher
education we have the pell grant for low
income kids with a gi bill for veterans
you can take the money to a public
private religious or non-religious
university it doesn't have to go to one
particular place based on your address
we do the same thing with head start and
pre-k programs the the families can
choose
religious or non-religious private
providers of pre-k
and that's the funding following the
student we do the same thing with food
stamps for grocery stores you can take
the money to walmart trader joe's
safeway you don't have to take the money
to a residentially assigned
government-run grocery store what
happens if everybody signs on to this
and then all the kids from the
surrounding area want to go to this one
school that's really good it overloads
their their
capacity they expand that's a good
problem to have currently if everybody
wants to go to that school today
they may want to do it in their minds
but they can't do it because they don't
have the financial means to do so when
they're already paying through the tax
system for the government schools d.c
public schools spend over 30 thousand
dollars per student per year but like
year one so everyone decides to go to
this big good school and only like 10
percent of them can get in because they
have 10 times the amount what happens is
it like do they have to draw a straw
first come first or do they raise the
price because supply and demand well new
schools pop up
people submit applications to open
charter schools all the time and and
schools typically will will expand
so if in one year too many students are
trying to enroll they'll say we've
better capacity so we've you know
through a random lottery these are the
ones that ought to come we're sorry but
we will be expanding next year so you
can next year but in the moment and
let's say you can't go to the best
school you can go to the second best
school it's better than having no
choices at all let's let's jump to this
uh thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there